Vous ne savez pas tout, vous n’avez pas
tout vu. Laissez-moi donc vous dire, monsieur
le professeur, que vous ne regretterez pas
le temps passé à mon bord. Vous allez voyager
dans le pays des merveilles. L’étonnement,
la stupéfaction seront probablement l’état
habituel de votre esprit. Vous ne vous blaserez
pas facilement sur le spectacle incessamment
offert à vos yeux. Je vais revoir dans un
nouveau tour du monde sous-marin, — qui
sait ? le dernier peut-être, — tout ce
que j’ai pu étudier au fond de ces mers
tant de fois parcourues, et vous serez mon
compagnon d’études. À partir de ce jour,
vous entrez dans un nouvel élément, vous
verrez ce que n’a vu encore aucun homme,
— car moi et les miens nous ne comptons
plus, — et notre planète, grâce à moi,
va vous livrer ses derniers secrets.
Bonjour, je m'appelle Jozée Sarrazin, on est le 25 juillet 1995
Je me lève à six heures, j’ai très mal
dormi mais je suis très heureuse. Je suis
super excitée car je vais plonger dans un
sous -marin habité. Et il faut savoir que
les sous-marins habités, il y en a moins
d’une dizaine dans le monde. C’est quand
même une opportunité géniale ! Je prends
un léger petit déjeuner, puis me prépare
pour cette première plongée. Je fais plus
ample connaissance avec Pat et Jym,
– mes collègues qui vont m’accompagner, et du sous-marin « Alvin ». On nous demande de prendre place à bord.
À l’intérieur, c’est très étroit, on a chacun un emplacement,
une espèce de siège sur lequel on va être
« à moitié » assis pendant les 8 heures de plongée.
À l’intérieur, on a chacun un hublot et il y a des boutons partout.
Dans cette sphère de 2 m3, on va être trois : deux scientifiques et un pilote.
On ferme les écoutilles du sous-marin, puis lentement on déplace le sous-marin vers l’arrière du bateau,
et puis on le descend à la surface de l’eau.
Nous commençons notre descente.
Nous sommes le 18 mai 1930 il est 10 heures 30 : Nous sommes enfin arrivé aux Bermudes.
Je suis William Beebe et je suis accompagné de mon ami Otis Barton,
je suis impatient de descendre dans ces
nouveaux lieux inexplorés grâce à la bathysphère que mon cher ami a construit.
14 heures : Je suis très stressé avant ce
grand voyage. Nous avons mangé de la salade et du poisson fraîchement péché.
Mon ami me demande si je me sens prêt pour ce voyage.
Je lui réponds que oui.
Un sentiment de confiance nous gagne tous deux.
16 heures : Je me situe sur le lieu de la
plongée, latitude : 32.29 longitude : -64.649,
tout l'équipage nous encourage et cela me
donne une envie de partir explorer, voyager, découvrir.
18 heures : Nous entrons dans la bathysphère pour vérifier que tout le matériel est opérationnel
: la structure, les vivres, la résistance à la pression, et celle du hublot
Nous sommes fin prêts pour ce premier test « à vide » .
20 heures : La bathysphère a fait sa première plongée, et notre cœur bat à cent à l'heure
lorsqu'elle remonte vide, en parfait état.
Otis et moi avons les larmes aux yeux, il est temps pour nous de partir !
Je suis Auguste Piccard, 25 octobre 1948
Je pense à mon fils qui a 26 ans.
J'espère revenir vivant.
J'espère faire des découvertes jusqu’ici
inconnues.
J'ai la boule au ventre.
Vérifier le matériel :
L'étanchéité
La ventilo
Le lest
Les flotteurs
La pompe a air
La décompression du sas
Ma femme m’a tricoté des chaussettes avec des cœurs, ce qui fait beaucoup rire mon co-équipier, Théodore Monod .
Je m’appelle Jacques Piccard. Je suis océanaute et océanographe.
Le 23 janvier prochain, en cette année 1960, je plongerais sur la fosse des Mariannes, en compagnie de Don Walsh.
J'ai vraiment très envie de voir ce qu'il y a dans les profondeurs.
Je ne sais pas si le sous-marin va tenir
et j'ai peur car je ne sais pas si je vais remonter en vie.
Je suis très fier de marcher sur les traces de mon père, Auguste Piccard.
Je m'appelle Ballard Je me trouve dans l'Atlantique nord, latitude : 39°, longitude : -50°
13 juillet 1985
Dans 1 semaine, je pars en exploration, il
me reste un peu de temps pour me préparer.
20 juillet 1985.
Je me trouve à bord du navire océanographique le Suroît. Je pars à la recherche de deux sous-marins nucléaires
qui appartenaient à la marine Américaine: Le Tresher et le Scorpion.
Cette expédition ne me réjouit
pas du tout mais elle nous permet de financer notre expédition de recherche de l’épave
du Titanic.
28 juillet 1985.
Nous avons enfin localisé les deux sous-marins.
Nous allons enfin pouvoir nous consacrer entièrement
à la recherche du Titanic au cours des prochaines semaines.
18 août je suis arrivé au Canada
Je suis très excité, mais j’ai aussi très peur d’échouer.
Heureusement, je suis accompagné des 25 meilleurs océanographes,
Archipel des Açores : latitude : 38.53°, longitude : -28.63°
Nom complet : HROV Ariane
Surnom : Ariane
Date de naissance : le 16 mars 2015
Nationalité : française
Profession : exploratrice des profondeurs
Zone d’activité : Océan Atlantique
Bateau d’appareillage : le Pourquoi-pas?
Profondeur de plongée : 2500m
Longueur : 2,20 mètres
Poids : 1,5 tonne
Vitesse : 0 à 2 nœuds
Communication : Fibre optique en mode télé opéré / acoustique en mode autonome
Batteries : Batterie Lithium-ion 14 à 20 KWh
Autonomie : 6 à 10 heures
Missions : Cartographie acoustique
Inspection locale très près du fond
Imagerie optique haute résolution géo-référencée
Prélèvements et mise en œuvre d’outils
légers
Nous sommes le 16 mars 2015. Je suis Ariane, le nouveau robot sous-marin d'IFREMER.
A ma sortie d'usine, je pensais être un satellite
Pour tout dire, je ne savais pas que j'allais travailler dans l'eau
Je suis installé sur le célèbre
navire scientifique de l’IFREMER, le Pourquoi Pas.
Je me prépare à ma première plongée. Je suis actuellement à 100 % de batterie
j'ai entendu dire l’équipage que je descendrai à 2000 mètres de profondeur...
moi qui suis hydrophobe et qui
ai peur de la noirceur des profondeurs, cela me fait très peur !
Doit-on s’étonner que toutes nos connaissances
sur ce qui se passe sous la mer soit
si cruellement, si désespérément, si scandaleusement
modeste ? Après tout s’il on y réfléchi
cela est fort explicable, malgré grande
activité déployée depuis trois quarts de siècle
dans la recherche océanographique
et en particulier l’exploration méthodique des eaux abyssales.
Nous avons dit plus haut
comment nous nous trouvions assez exactement
dans la situation d’un Monsieur contraint
d’habiter sur le toit, incapable d’en descendre
et qui cherchait de là-haut
à deviner le contenu de l’immeuble.
Nos coups de drague, de chalut, de filet vertical demeurent par rapport à l’immensité
des surfaces sporadiques, ridiculement accidentelles...
Dans la sphère, il commence à faire plus
froid. Je coiffe ma tuque...
Très rapidement, la lumière se fait de plus en plus rare...
et puis on arrive très rapidement à un noir absolu.
De temps en temps, il y a de petits
organismes qui font de la bioluminescence.
Et qui passent à travers le hublot. C’est
très beau. En arrière fond, il y a de la musique
c’est Pink Floyd The Wall. Il nous reste encore plus de 30 minutes avant l’arrivée au fond
Jym a une envie pressante, il est
donc obligé de faire ses besoins dans un bocal. C'est un peu gênant.
Enfin, au bout d’une heure et demi : Il est 9H00. Il fait très froid en même temps à 2500 m de profondeur.
L'objectif de cette expédition est de trouver la cheminée que je convoite depuis environ un mois.
Cinq minutes plus tard, nous atteignons la cible et nous contemplons les fameux geysers volcaniques.
Comme c'est beau !  Les crevettes y sont abondantes. Pat et Jym eux, n'ont pas l'air très surpris.
Il faut dire qu'ils ont plus d'expérience que moi !
22 heures : Le moment que nous attendions tous est enfin arrivé :
nous embarquons dans la bathysphère, puis elle est mise à l’eau.
23 heures : Nous sommes plongés dans un noir total et nous attendons patiemment ne serait-ce qu'un signe
quand, tout à coup, un grand
poisson se colle au hublot. Nous sommes très surpris !
Mon ami m'informe que nous atteignons
les 923mètres de profondeur !
Puis une lumière venue des ténèbres nous illumine. Je contemple la source de cette lumière :
c’est un poisson lanterne, qui nous permet de regarder ce magnifique milieu marin.
Il y a plein de couleurs magnifiques, de récifs aux formes extravagantes.
Auguste Piccard 26 octobre 1948
Nous sommes arrivés à boa-vista, au Cap-Vert.
COORDONÉES :
16° 06′ 12″ N, 22° 48′ 13″ O
La descente est agitée à cause d'une mer
mouvementée. Dès que nous sommes sous l’eau,
nous voyons plein d'espèces de poissons différentes.
Il fait noir dans le sous-marin. Et il y fait très froid.
Seul le bruit du sonar, un « bip-bip
» incessant trouble mes pensées.
Avec mon collègue, nous observons fiévreusement à travers le hublot, le vide et le noir.
Les lieux sont d'une beauté rare et inconnue
sur terre. Chaque fois que nous croisons la
route d’un poisson des profondeurs, nous
sommes émerveillés et époustouflés
de la différence avec ceux de la surface. Seulement, nous avons du mal à respirer, il fait extrêmement sombre et froid.
Il fait d’ailleurs si froid
que nos petits suisses ont gelé.
Après une descente interminable, nous arrivons enfin au fond. Nous allumons le projecteur,
et apercevons un fond vide et blanc. Seules
quelques espèces de crevettes blanches flânent
autour du sous-marin. Mon collègue est désopilant. Il est bouche-bée d'émerveillement.
Une petite pause, pour prendre le temps de se féliciter d'être arrivé jusqu’ici.
C'est un exploit dont nous pouvons être fiers.
Nous avons atteint 3150 M ! Une distance impensable pour notre époque.
Et beaucoup de gens vont nous considérer comme fous, inconscients et irresponsables.
Mais grâce à cette découverte
et cet exploit, nous leurs prouvons que
nous ne sommes pas fous mais juste ambitieux ! Nous
avons réalisé un rêve d'enfant.
Jacques Piccard, 23 janvier 1960
Lorsqu’on commence à descendre, on voit
le ciel et la mer se mélanger.
Le soleil disparaît de plus en plus. Le bathyscaphe tremble beaucoup ça nous fait très peur.
Il fait de plus en plus noir. Nous restons
en contact avec la surface.
Après quatre heures de descente nous touchons enfin le fond.
Nous sommes à 10 916 mètres de profondeur.
Il fait très noir et on a très froid.
On prend donc des bouillottes pour nous réchauffer.
Le premier poisson qu'on voit en
bas est plat. Il fait à peu près 30cm de long.
On lui nomme Auguste, en hommage à
mon père, dont je suis très fier.
18 août 1995, je suis Ballard
Après l’échec d’une tentative de recherche,
je décide de scruter le fond de l’océan
grâce à l'Argot, un robot sous-marin.
1er septembre 1985
Le robot sous-marin Argot que nous avons envoyé quelques jours plus tôt,
a découvert les vestiges d'une chaudière.
Je sens que nous sommes proches de l’épave du Titanic et que nous sommes sur le point de la trouver.
14 heures
Nous avons enfin localisé le Titanic
par 3780 mètres de profondeur, en latitude 41 et en longitude -49. Je suis très heureux.
17 heures
Ma joie est de courte durée car nous ne retrouvons pas
d'ossements humains et le paquebot est divisé en deux parties.
Nous devons partir à la recherche de la 2eme partie du paquebot.
Ça y est, on m'accroche au treuil et on me
positionne au-dessus de l'eau.
Je vois les reflets du soleil briller sur l'eau claire.
Le capitaine de mission me demande d'activer mes projecteurs
Je descend sous la surface de l'eau je vois les rayons du soleil traverser la fine couche d'eau
Je sens le treuil se détacher.
Je regarde au-dessus de moi, et je peux voir la coque du Pourquoi-Pas.
En entamant la descente, j’aperçois un banc de poissons. Ils m'effraient, bien qu’ils soient inoffensifs.
Je ne me sens pas vraiment en sécurité. Je me sens d’ailleurs de moins en moins en sécurité à mesure que l’on descend.
Je regarde derrière moi et tombe directement nez-à-nez avec un requin.
Je me décide à prendre la fuite à toute vitesse. Malheureusement je tombe face à un mur.
Je suis coincé entre un mur et un requin, ce requin n'est pas ce que je trouve dans ma base de données.
Il a l'air plus ancien, comme une sorte de requin préhistorique.
Je sens ma peur de l'eau me glacer l'essence. Au moment où le requin me fonce dessus,
plusieurs baleines lui barrent la route, et grâce à cette distraction parfaite, je peux prendre la fuite vers les profondeurs.
En remontant de cette plongée, tu as l’impression d’avoir fait un long voyage
de revenir de très loin... Tout d’un coup
tu reviens, tu partages avec les autres.
Pendant les huit heures tu reste dans ton espace, et tous les gens attendent aussi sur le pont.
Ça aussi tu le découvres par le hublot.
Les gens qui se massent sur le pont arrière du bateau
pour assister à l’arrivée du sous-marin, et pour avoir des détails.
Tu sens que tu es attendu. Que ce que tu as fait, ça avait son importance.
L'équipage entier nous a acclamé
lorsque nous sommes sortis de la bathysphère
qui de plus, a parfaitement tenu et était
en parfait état. Nous sommes fiers d'avoir réussi à
construire un sous-marin capable
de descendre jusqu’à 923 mètre de profondeur !
Il est temps pour nous de faire un premier bilan de nos découvertes !
Nous avons vu des poissons, des crustacés et des coraux aux formes extravagantes. Nous avons même découvert une nouvelle espèce !
Des chercheurs nous ont laissé le choix de son nom, nous l'avons nommé le ''Scorlion''
à cause de sa crinière et de sa sorte de nageoire dorsale ressemblant à des pinces.
Otis et moi sommes entrés dans l'histoire. Désormais nous n'avons plus qu'un seul objectif en tête  :
battre ce nouveau record et renforcer notre bathysphère
Lorsque le bathyscaphe est sorti de l’eau,
il nous faut attendre une bonne vingtaine de minutes,
le temps de l'ouverture du sas et du dévissage. Pour patienter, Théodore et moi cherchons des noms
pour quelques-unes des découvertes
que nous avons faites.
Parmi les espèces nouvelles que nous avons découvert, mes deux préférés sont le Marly,
un petit poisson tout bleu, qui adore se cacher et l’Emixache un petit poisson fluorescent.
Jacques Piccard nous sommes impatients de remonter à la surface.
Lorsque nous arrivons sur le
pont du bateau, les journalistes nous interrogent,
nous bousculent, nous harcèlent. Je n’arrête pas de sourire. Je suis heureux de raconter
la plongée à mon fils. Il boit mes paroles
et me fixe avec des yeux brillants. Je suis tellement fier de mon exploit !
9 septembre 1985 : Mission réussie ! Nous réussissons à localiser le reste du paquebot.
Nous allons pouvoir laisser les scientifiques faire leur travail sur l’épave.
15 septembre 1985 : Nous rentrons à Terres Neuves très exaltés.
Le soir, nous faisons la fête pour célébrer cette découverte pendant des heures.
Je suis perdu. Je ne vois que de la noirceur.
Plus aucune lumière de la surface ne parvient jusqu’ici.
Pourtant je vois une étrange lumière au loin. Ça ressemble à une étoile sous l'eau
mais ça ne peut pas être possible ! Je me rapproche et je m’éteins en voyant la monstruosité de ce poisson lanterne.
C'est un diable noir ! Je suis pris de panique.
J’en ai même oublié ma batterie ! Je suis
a 56% d’autonomie, et j'ai perdu contact avec l'équipage en surface.
Je parviens a récupérer le signal radio
avec le Pourquoi Pas?
Mais je sens dans ce froid intense qui me torture, de la chaleur, énormément de chaleur.
Je découvre une cheminée hydrothermale. Je distingue des milliers et des milliers de petites crevettes
dansant avec la fumée de la cheminée. C’est un spectacle magnifique !
Malheureusement il ne me reste plus que 37% de batterie et il est temps pour moi d’entamer ma remontée.
Au terme d’une longue remontée, il ne me
reste plus que 3% de batterie...
Il était temps ! Moi qui avais peur de l'eau, je suis très heureux de cette première expédition.
J'ai enfin réalisé mon rêve mais finalement
l'océan est plus inconnu que l'espace !
Il faut savoir qu’on connait très peu encore
les environnements marins profonds, mais qu’avec
la découverte de nouveaux écosystèmes,
de nouvelles formes de vies on a aussi découvert
de nouvelles ressources potentielles... Que
ce soit des ressources biologiques, des ressources
minérales ou énergétiques... Et il y a
un grand engouement pour tout ce qui est ressources
minérales dans les grands fonds, parce qu’on
en utilise beaucoup pour ce qui est électronique
Et donc il y a dans de plus en plus de pression
pour aller explorer et exploiter.
Les grands fonds sont des environnements encore peu connus, mais ils sont déjà menacés !
Moi je voudrais faire découvrir les grands fonds au plus grand nombre... faire rêver les gens sur
ces environnements magnifiques, qui font partie
de notre planète
pour donner l’envie de les protéger !